so Doron Holly can stay up here because
it's now time for the YC partner panel
hi everyone I'm Sharon Pope I work at YC
I run marketing programs and I want to
just remind you that you can submit
questions so go to slide o comm SLI do
comm if you don't have a question you
particularly want to ask you an upvote
someone else's and I'm taking the
questions from you so please if you
haven't yet go ahead and submit and I
will just stand
great no I like standing are we okay
with me standing good okay oh and the
Salado event code is FFC thank you Amy
sly TOCOM event code FFC all right so
starting off this was one of the more
popular questions that's come through so
far for FEMA founders who have families
are there remote options for YC or what
options are available for participating
in YC if you don't live in Silicon
Valley oh yeah so recently we put out
something called the YC family user
manual actually Amy and Sharron worked
really closely on that and so it's
essentially we give it to all our
founders when they join the batch and
it's tips and advice for people who have
families on how to balance that
resources they can use and so what we've
seen a lot of both moms and dads come
through YC and they've all you know sort
of made it work in different ways and so
we've seen folks who have you know there
have been cases where they brought the
whole family they've been in cases where
they've kind of commuted back and forth
is there anything so the short answer is
it is not a remote program and part of
part of it is the benefit of building
that trust building that interaction
seeing that feeling that live I just
think it's honestly and the word strong
but a bit of a lost opportunity I was
gonna say waste if you don't come there
so we actually have an international
founder in our group she just had a baby
is six months old and she is doing a
company in Mexico and we have a ton of
international founders that actually fly
back and forth mainly because the
business is over there and then they
come over for the dinners and the group
office hours because it's just so much
important for her business to kind of
move forward so we have a lot of support
stuff like the user family manual that
comes I've definitely seen there's
another group in my in my batch right
now he brought his three month old son
and three year old I'm like here are all
the parks you could go to here are all
the other things you could go to
particularly for women who there's a lot
of support also as well for nursing moms
there's also really good blog posts by a
female founder YC who talked about
making it work particularly while she
was nursing so it's just it just is a
lost opportunity if you're just not
there I will say that well we'll make
sure to tweet that article out so people
can after we'll share it out so everyone
can take a look um so what another
question what industries or technology
is does YC think are extremely promising
right now so one of the things I think
that is exciting about what YC is that
we get a lot of applications every six
months and we get to see sort of it's
like seeing into a crystal ball so ideas
from some of the smartest most creative
people around the world come to us and
so I think some of the best ideas that
we've ever funded and some of the best
ideas out there aren't even things that
we would necessarily think of it's just
you know what you're all working on that
we get to get insight into that said
there are trends there's a really great
blog post at one of our partners put out
if you look up to startup site-geist and
it shows
eight years of data from YC application
so it's shows sort of the trends that
we've seen like in 2011 we saw a ton of
Bitcoin applications you know in about
two years ago everyone was building chat
BOTS or things on top of slack and so I
think that's the most exciting parts of
what we do it's not calling what's going
to be the next big thing but getting to
I get see into you know a little bit
into the future of what might be
so in terms of ideas too that have come
to mind one is retail and in particular
I think brick-and-mortar is trying to go
online now and online pure plays are
trying to figure out brick-and-mortar
there's like a clash of cultures there
and no one has really figured that out
so well I think there's a lots to do
there in women's retail and all and all
these all these categories I think I
mean obviously Amazon's a big player on
the online retail and they're trying to
move offline - but I think there's a lot
of room there for lots of startups to
win there and then the second one is I
actually haven't I feel like it's a
little bit like blockchain but like
voice apps so every home like almost
every home now has an Alexa or Google
home or one of these things
there have been no great applications
like the biggest thing that people use
it for is just information retrieval or
reminders or stuff like that but the UX
is quite odd and it's it's not how we
let how we as adults like are used to
using things so I think there's a lot of
user UX stuff to do there and figure out
what that what those apps will look like
but yeah I think we I think everyone
thinks that like watch-chain voice is
the future but no one it's figure out
great applications for it and so I'm
always curious when people are working
out what this could be the other thing
is you know we've we've talked a bit
about how we have applications from all
sorts of technologies and we actually
put out what we call a request for
startups which talk about some of the
things that maybe you know we'd love to
see applications from but one thing to
bear in mind is just because what you're
working on isn't one of those that
doesn't mean that we're not looking for
it you know we want you to tell us what
we should be interested in
so don't kind of self select yourself
out because it's not one of the things
that we mentioned it's something that we
that we hear people saying well YC isn't
looking for companies like mine and we
totally are because we're just looking
for great companies so related question
a lot of people are asking about what
qualities if the companies and founders
you find most attractive and also the
red flags in an apple
I feel like we addressed the company's
question but Kersey you've seen a
thousand companies go through what what
is it about founders in terms of what
you look for but also red flags I don't
think because we're looking at so many
of these companies at such an early
stage we're really really focusing in on
the founders themselves and so we want
to see people who are determined who
aren't going to give up the minute that
things get a little bit tough
particularly where there are teams of
co-founders we want to be able to to see
that there is some existing relationship
there and it's not just somebody that
you met in a coffee shop two weeks ago
and brainstormed for two hours and it's
all going to be amazing you know as
you've heard from from pretty much
everybody today you know the co-founder
relationship is so incredibly important
because it's it's something that will
get you through the lows and the highs
and you know they will understand what
you're going through you will understand
what they're going through and one of
the number one reasons that we see
startups failing is actually that the
the founder relationship breaks down so
so a lot of the things that we're
looking for in the applications are
around do we think the founding team is
going to be that that really amazing
team that can that can make this work a
one tell we have in that way as we look
at the equity split so we like to see
teams that have as close to equal equity
as possible between the co-founders and
and that's because you know even if
someone came up with the idea one was
working on it six months or so before
you know sometimes we'll see you know I
came up with the idea so I have 80% and
my co-founder is 20% but the reality is
a vast majority of your companies like
life is in the future it takes it I
think at an average of 10 years now to
IPO or exit so you want the co-founders
to be on as equal footing as possible
if I could sum it up in one word like
founders that are just formidable like
I'm like okay they're just gonna do it
regardless regardless of what happens
here in this room in the interviewing
room and I think that that's one of the
things that we find and we'd love to
find I will touch a note on two things
one around the technical
founders so and having teams we do love
teams but we've accepted solo founders
as well we've cept that non-technical
founders as well but the reason why we
anchor against those is it's only three
months that YC is happening and if you
don't have somebody that can actually
build and do something then you're
losing time on learning and it's really
really difficult and finally I was I was
talking to actually I'll pick on you we
were like when you're in a particular
space particularly if it's very crowded
I'm very interested in like what types
of insights do you have like I was
talking to Amy about her insights I was
like wow that totally makes sense
increasing the village on childcare and
that I think is just something if you're
thinking about - I have another question
for you adore as well all right so the
next question so we've talked about
knowing your numbers and how it's so
important but maybe it's even more
important for female founders so adore
when you're considering an investment
are considering an applicant to YC what
metrics are you most focused on what do
you think are the most important ones -
that they're tracking and that they know
rock-solid well if if they haven't built
anything yet there's I guess nothing to
really look at except for just
understanding what the market
opportunity is - is they're starting to
build you know one of the things that we
tell every founder is you should instead
of growing really really really fast the
first thing you should do is build a
product that people really really love
and so that could be defined as you know
that Wow so so then I would say the
question is what are the metrics that
define what happy engaged users are
happy engaged users getting continuous
value out of the product and so it's
it's different for every single company
but usually you can get like three to
four key metrics that kind of give you a
360 over overview of what that means so
it could be like weekly active users MPs
retention is a huge one you should
always be looking at retention meaning
you know five you know 100 people came
this month how many stayed the next
month and so on and so forth
and so that's that's a quantitative way
to look at and so we would always
probably ask for those kind of metrics
and then the more qualitative is like
when you're talking to people you can
kind of get a feel of you know how you
know how good your product is already or
how much they value it so for example if
they should if you say
if you ask them Oh what would you think
and they're like oh that's pretty cool
that that's that doesn't feel like you
know they're happy engaged but if
they're like oh my god Holly how can I
get an invite link so I can send it to
20 of my friends now like there's a huge
difference there and so that's a more of
a qualitative thing that you can get out
of that and I think to Abney's point
earlier is they're like it she was
saying you have seven weeks until the
application deadline so start and start
tracking and make some progress do you
think that there's is there a period of
time you look at in terms of the metrics
or is it more flexible um it's this
entire period when you start at building
and started using and just you want to
see some growth in terms of you know
your MPs is getting better your weekly
active users are getting better and I
mean the metrics tell you the what and
but you need to deep dive and know what
the why so that you can continue doing
the things I keep working
maybe I'm surprisingly a question maybe
Kat will answer um this room wants to
know if YC will ever have a Seattle
office or accelerator I think for now
and I travel a lot internationally all
around the US and I think for at this
point in history it still helps most
companies to spend three months in the
Bay Area there is just it's so easy to
raise money there there's a huge no I
mean it's relatively relatively I mean
you know it's hard but it's much easier
than pretty much anywhere else in the
world and then there is just ever you
know a huge network of founders and so
spending three months building that
network of investors and other founders
who can help you out as you grow I think
makes sense and then you can come back
and and bring that network and all that
knowledge with you back here or back you
know wherever your users are the one
thing I my sort of hope is the way that
we get you know organically get Y C's
all over the world is that we fund a
really incredible company you know they
grow Pompey I'm looking at you or shift
Labs they grow they become
billion-dollar companies and their
founders start reinvesting in the
ecosystem so that you know they start
investing in the founders here and so
that's I think the most my dream for YC
long-term is that it's the alumni in
each of these regions that sort of grow
the whole community I think that's great
so question and obviously we've seen
some great YC alums on stage today
how does YC interact with founders after
YC so it's a fairly common misconception
that people think that YC ends after the
three-month program and actually that's
not true at all because we are still
investors in your company and and we're
here to help you know we want to help
the founders that have been through the
batch already and so we're here as a as
a resource we're always available to ask
answer questions whenever founders come
back to us and so some examples of
things that we we help with after the
the batch you know the maybe the
founders have raised a million dollars
out of demo day and they're now a year
past that and they're thinking about
starting to raise their series a and we
can come and we'll help them pull
together a pitch deck will help them
with their practice pitchers we you know
will will introduce them to people who
could be helpful and then continuing on
we also now have later stage program
where we work with companies who maybe
have 50 employees or a hundred employees
and how do we how do those companies
scale and how can they you know what
sort of problems are they coming across
that we can help with and so the idea is
is that we are always a resource for you
know everybody who's been through YC and
so any of our any of our experience if
we can be helpful we we want to be
helpful to you and on the back end we've
built a lot of software so we have
something called Bookface it's like it's
like Facebook meets LinkedIn meets Quora
where all of our founders sort of
everyday are sort of talking to each
other asking questions helping each
other out and I think more often than
you know founders will come to us
occasionally if they have questions
especially around fundraising but I
think more often they're asking their
community the community of founders to
help each other out so that's I think
those touch points happen on a monthly
basis if not more yeah
I'll just time in and say another
misconception is that ycs about the
three months and so and this doesn't
necessarily you don't have to take them
up on it but office hours are open for
any founder for any partner afterwards
and so for me two years out of YC I
actually take way more value out of that
then even during the period when it was
very intense and there's a lot of stuff
and you're mostly working with your
group partners there are people that
have experience across the board there
are former venture partners their former
founders obviously they're from
everything across the board and so for
me when I talked about mentors most of
my mentors are actually YC partners and
so the ability for me to every month or
whatever it is own reaching out to them
and having that has been so invaluable
so for those of you that are kind of
evaluating YC as a program don't ever
think about it as just like a
three-month thing it's sort of like a
lifelong you get into this tribe of
people and founders that I think is just
so invaluable Thank You Avenue founder
of poppy just I loved that so I think
that and this is obviously something
that actually I think if Holly on adora
want to take this one so as a founder
how do you keep the momentum going when
the funds are running dry and growth is
getting really challenging or maybe I
guess I guess if it would help to put a
finer point on it can you talk through a
time where you felt that crunch and how
you were able to push through it whether
it was fully dry or super depressing so
I started we started a company in 2006
exited in 2017 and 2008 was the worst
year ever for all startups everywhere
around the world but particularly in
Silicon Valley a big venture capitalists
called Sequoia Capital had sent out a
deck said our IP good times get to
cashflow positive and there was just no
money anywhere so for us what we did so
a it's obviously super I have a
co-founding team of four total and good
news as we got along which was great and
we were pretty cheap so we got even
cheaper we cut our we cut our burn
drastically
and we basically hunker down all of us
in some ways because we were smaller it
felt really good that we were all in the
same boat together for about two to
three years our Christmas party was
basically an office party with board
games but nobody really complain too
much so that's pretty good with a gift
exchange which is great
and I think the other thing that we did
that was for us and I'm not saying it's
for everybody but we did change our
business model during that time because
we saw basically three million dollar
contracts just disappear overnight and
we said we just cannot kind of function
with that and we were just stupid enough
to just try to continue to exist during
that time until funding came in about a
year later and that's when we just
walked down to the pub and had a drink
after the money goes in the bank so by
the way term sheets are sign that means
nothing you gotta wait till money's in
the bank
so the first three years of that we were
around we actually only were able to
raise a hundred and a hundred thousand
dollars and so for the Bay Area that's
not a lot of money so I mean the number
one rule in a startup before especially
if you don't a product market fit yet is
just to keep your personal burn low so
you got a you know you yeah you can't
spend money on anything only on the the
must needs so I mean we couldn't afford
board games I guess you could apart
there's the library check out you could
check them up but honestly it's just
keeping your personal burn low and just
having a good relationship with your
co-founder and just being on the same
page of where you're going and keep
trying and just like you guys pivot oh
we actually it's funny because we
pivoted also into the thing that started
growing then got us venture capital
during this time when we were just like
on credit cards and and barely making it
so we pivot in indie games yeah like
that mentality it's like that that
mentality of not yet you don't have
anything really makes you think it makes
your be really efficient with what you
do and it really makes you think
what you can do with very little and I
think that's actually when some of the
better ideas come about so even if you
raise money you should always keep that
in mind and keep that mentality and
mindset and always keep your burnt low
okay so another interesting question
especially for this conference are there
differences that you've seen in
interviews between male founders and
female founders in terms of how they
present etc Christy do want to start see
so I guess of of the women that have
come in and the women that we have taste
so I don't know in terms of pitching but
I do realize there's one thing that I
realized not just from this one but over
time is partly for I've heard this
advice given to men about in order to
sound very smart is to speak slower but
I feel like that advice doesn't help for
women actually think the ones that just
bowled us over with the numbers of like
this is this this this and this and
we're like wow okay and those were the
ones that we ended up taking it was like
okay that that like they just didn't
even give in edgewise in some ways it's
not like they weren't listening either
you definitely have to be open to
listening but I'd have to think a little
bit on was there a difference in terms
or maybe itching as founders who have
pitched investors were there things that
you kind of had to coach yourself on
that you had to improve upon yeah
definitely I know some of the stuff
sounds really silly but doing those
Superman poses like getting your head in
the game the visualization pieces
practice practice practice practice
practice practice and know your numbers
but I'll let you talk about them
honestly I think it's like knowing your
numbers I don't know that's just the
number one thing and I always just knew
my numbers and was able to if you asked
me anything I would I could tell you in
a split second and I think I think
that's super important I think
confidence just going in and even if
it's like I said before even if it's
super awkward feeling just just being
confident there's and
it was really funny because when I was
asking for money I'd always like smile
weirdly or like like almost crack up
because it was just so awkward for me so
I just had to get out of that phase and
just because there's always a silence
also after you asked and you should
dispose don't start like some people
just start rambling after that because
the other person hasn't spoken yet but
it's you know just pause and wait for
the reaction so I was I was talking to a
lot of the international founders and
one French founder actually a man a male
French founder you know came up to me
and said you know demo day is coming up
and I have to say I'm really
uncomfortable because you know American
men pitch themselves in such this like
overblown bold way and we're not taught
like to speak like that in France I mean
it's very embarrassing and uncomfortable
and so it's just something that we had
to practice it that he you know could
fight past that discomfort because you
have to you know a lot of investors are
sort of used to seeing these you know
kind of bold confident pitches and so
that is something that I think you know
you know international founders but also
I see some women like kind of undersell
themselves I was reading hackathon
applications a couple years ago it was
the first time I noticed it would be
teams mixed teams male female and you
know the male on the team would say hey
we built this world-changing
award-winning hack at this last you know
hackathon we're an incredible team we're
the best on the planet stuff like that
and his female counterpart who had built
that same you know hack with him said
you know I contributed to this product
and it was really like a stark contrast
and it's something that I saw over and
over again and so it just made me
whenever I talk to women I'm like don't
undersell you know what you're doing or
what you're bringing to this team
because you're an important piece of it
and so that's I think a main thing that
I tell women over and over again before
they go out and pitch and don't
apologize
I'm practicing that I'm sorry I have one
more question I have a couple more
questions but I just wanted to do that
um so what would be the advice so we we
are at YC I've obviously seen a lot of
companies go from that early stage to
the growth stage so what do you think
some of the best advice is for that for
a company as they're getting to that
next phase and made either like getting
over 30 employees approaching 50
employees so there's there's two sides
to it there's one the product side in
terms of how do you grow your product
and the most important thing is knowing
your unit economics like at the one unit
level how much does how much money are
you making on each piece or each person
that comes in because then you could
dump a bunch of money in there and be
and it's gonna be smart how it's gonna
be spent so on your product side you
should definitely know how your unit
economics are and they should be
positive just in case anybody does not
know it should be positive and I know it
might be a little different for
advertising based company and even b2b
it looks at AR our average annual
recurring revenue and all that but for
the most part if you get your unit
economics right then that that is
something that's that's important as you
grow there's something that changes also
from partic market fit the organization
changes and I think people don't talk
about that as much but that is
incredibly important to be able to
enable your product to grow and from
that stage it's almost like I'm pretty
sure that the CEO gets hurt hit first in
terms of feeling that kind of like okay
it's time to scale like I don't even
know where the keys to the building are
like how do I even get in there and then
it starts hitting the next layer perhaps
like for us it was the other co-founders
such as myself I'm like I don't even
know where the files are the design
files because I hired another designer
and at that point you start thinking
about well about managing all of this
stuff you're like oh my god this is big
corporate stuff I'm here to get [ __ ]
done right and what people don't realize
is when you get [ __ ] done sometimes you
just end up with a lot of [ __ ] oh my
gosh this is being recorded
livestreams stops done stuff so sorry
for everybody out there
oh no colleges ain't sorry I'm not
supposed anyways the problem with that
mindset especially as you're growing is
you end up with just a lot of crap and
you have people doing the same thing in
like three or four different places and
you're just like what is going on and so
you have to start moving into a mindset
of making it happen like looking at it
as a whole organize this or get like
organism particularly those that are
leading the company and then you as
founders which i think is incredibly a
difficult special and probably
irrational place to be is that it's it's
you have to learn how to scale yourself
and that's something that take a lot of
confidence and pride and that your
founder and we all know that you're
learning on the job and every day you're
failing every single day the learning
curve is like like 50% is a phenomenal
score because it's on a on a curve so
that those are things that you have to
kind of learn in terms of like how do
you start managing through people how do
you start knowing delegation and how you
yourself like how do you you yourself
recharge and be able to work with other
folks so but there's a lot of other
pieces on setting up an organization but
that's something that you start thinking
about you know you're building an
organization and then a company
all right so primary person just one
thing that what we see startups that
don't work out one of the things that
they always do is that they run out of
money because what they've done is while
they're growing they've just thrown
humans at problems like the human
band-aid solution isn't it's not thing
you should do meaning you know you just
hire as many engineers as you can
because you know you have all these
features you want to build and your
product roadmaps behind or you know you
don't have enough lead so you go hire
more marketing people you should not do
that and just think of other ways be
more to be more efficient and get back
like I said to that startup mindset of
being super efficient awesome
um another question and maybe Kirsty you
could take this one how do you how does
YC you feel about companies that have
already raised the money so they're
applying and they maybe have is there is
there an amount that's too much for them
to have them
cap table before they apply to I see so
we we have companies apply and companies
that we accept who have raised have
millions of dollars in the past it's a
real spectrum and another misconception
is people will will say I'm too early
for YC or I'm too late for YC and
actually neither of those things are
true so you will apply and we'll do our
job and figure out whether whether you
know you're the right fit and so you
know we do have companies that have come
to us having already raised money on
safes some companies have already raised
seed rounds you know and and we think
that the the three-month batch in
particular you know we can be really
helpful to any companies who are sort of
up to series a and sometimes even having
raised a Series A so you know I think
it's it's less about the dollars that
you've raised and more about where are
you in the process and and you know how
how can you leverage YC in the three
months that you get as part of the
program to actually make the company as
much of a success as it possibly can and
I just the last question we have a lot
of versions of kind of the flip side of
that question so we've talked a little
bit about like how someone can show
progress early but um what are in terms
of early stage companies what are some
of like how early can you possibly get
into YC and I think maybe would help to
just give some examples of founders
who've gotten in a little bit on the
earlier side and what the reasons might
have been so so we definitely have
companies who are super early you know
we'll often have people who come in and
we agree to fund who haven't even
incorporated yet so they're that early
you know and it it depends on on what
was the idea and what's going on in
terms of the company but also bear in
mind that even companies or founders can
come in with an idea that they've been
working on for six months or for a year
and during the three months of the batch
they decide to pivot into something
entirely different
so they're starting from absolute zero
as well so you know it doesn't always
just have to be at the points of the
applique
and any any early usage or any early
indicators of people really loving what
it is that you're building is is often
enough for us to be able to to take that
bet on you I'll just plug that YC has a
program called startup school startup
school org and will be another program
later this year which is literally
anyone who has an idea can participate
in that and and watch that content I
think that's it I guess I'll have the
last word thank you so much to the YC
partners and thank you to everyone I'll
head over cool I have a couple thank you
[Applause]
you